hi um sounds like my mic is working okay
great um so yeah uh my name is Carl
vogle I'm a principal data scientist
company called Baby list uh I am here to
nominally talk about AB testing
um this is the if you you probably know
by now but this is how you ask questions
I'll try and leave a minute at the end
uh otherwise feel free to acost me in
the hallway
um but I'd like to start with a story um
and in this story you are a data
scientist which is hopefully not super
hard to imagine um and you work at a
company that like sells goods or
services online and one day a product
manager comes up to you asking about a
test they want to run for some feature
they want to launch and this is not this
is like a substantial feature it's not
we're not like moving a button on the
page somewhere we're not like changing
some copy designers were involved
Engineers were involved you know this is
part of like a broader user experience
strategy we're trying to do and um you
get like that perennial question that
perennial data question of like how much
data do I need for this or um in this
case how long should I be running this
experiment and now you are a competent
and like a diligent data scientist
hopefully that's also not hard to
imagine um and you ask some thoughtful
questions about well what are you trying
to measure and what do success and
failure look like for this feature and
importantly like how big of a conversion
lift are we looking to get here to make
this worthwhile and the product manager
sort of struggles with these questions a
little bit but you get answers and you
run off and do the thing you were
trained to do and you do like some
sample size and some power calculations
and you figure out like an expected test
length and you get back to them and you
say well you're going to need six weeks
for this to test this feature and they
go that's great thank you for this we
have budget appetite for two weeks um
and so you like take a deep breath and
and um you wish them well uh and you
warn them that they may not be able to
detect the kind of effects they're
interested in in two weeks um and they
seem oddly okay with that warning
they're like okay cool um and two weeks
pass and you go take a look at the data
and like lo and behold there is a
conversion lift in this new feature and
if it were real it would mean meaningful
amount of money for the for the company
um but given the test length and sample
size it's not statistically significant
and you go back and you report this to
them and they respond to you with three
words and now you have maybe studied and
applied experimental methods for a long
time for many years and you have never
heard these three words before um but
they're called launch on neutral or
maybe they said launch on flat but
either way it basically means hey I
heard you it's not statistically
significant but it's positive and I'm
going to launch the feature anyway um
and you respond you know you have a very
like logical response to this right
um but you are introspective and you are
curious and when you are done like
raging about the lack of respect for
type 1 error rates or whatever right um
you start asking stakeholders like hey
what's the deal like why do we do this
why do we like run an underpowered test
and then like launch on an insignificant
result um and if you're like me you
might get answers kind of like this
right you're going to hear about like
some like faith in a broader strategy or
like wanting to launch something and
learn and iterate on it and all this
stuff and this will starts to make you
think about like AB testing in your
organization like a little bit
differently as something that has like
attributes that make it distinct from
just like the raw application of like
null hypothesis significance testing
right and some of these attributes are
that you know the features we test are
not just like coming off of a conveyor
belt like randomly drawn out of a
population of ideas that like might make
us money might lose US money like who
knows right they are carefully planned
they are Road mapped they have a lot of
path dependencies between each other um
you know um one what we do in the next
feature depends on like what we see in
this one and all this sort of stuff
right
secondly like we always struggle to have
these conversations about like sample
size and test design with folks because
you need some effect size input into it
and they always struggle to tell you
that and that is because by the time we
have gotten to the test we have sunk all
the cost of deploying the feature it is
basically pushing a button at that point
so any lift is good any lift is cool
let's do that right
um and we're like talking to them in
these terms of like type one and type
two error rates and this is just like
doesn't correspond to how like these
decision makers are thinking about the
RIS in this decision they just kind of
like want to make more money than they
lose on average and like never lose too
much money at a time and it's really
hard to like map this to like the false
positive and false negative rates
conditioned on like a null hypothesis
right um they are asking us this
question essentially right how do I make
a good decision about the effect size I
see and we are handing them some tools
that go well here are some statistical
guarantees on an inference you might
want to make and so there's a little bit
of a mismatch um and they end up
misusing the tools or ignoring the tools
um and this is kind of what this talk is
about is when we see this happening um
the instinct is kind of like correct
their use of the tool but I want to
argue in the AB testing context we maybe
want to think about handing them
slightly different tools um and so for
the rest of my time I am going to talk
about um two approaches to to to
thinking about Navy tests that have
helped me have like more productive
conversations with decision
makers
um so the first approach is uh
non-inferiority test designs which are
not new and not esoteric um but I think
they're slept on in the in the AB
testing context uh a little more than
they ought to be um you'll notice the
picture here is a guard rail and that is
that that's that's the metaphor to keep
in
mind uh the main idea of this approach
is that instead of testing whether the
new version of the site is better than
the current one we're just going to test
whether it's not worse by some margin
and that Marg margin is the delta in the
red box there and we call that the
inferiority
margin what is this bias um well when
you have a conversation about what these
margins ought to be you are forcing
conversations about the sort of things
that motivate these like launch on
neutral type decisions about you know
well how much do you want to risk to
launch this thing how much do you
believe in it how quickly are you going
to iterate on it and improve on it after
it's launched right and stakeholders can
kind of start to give you like
meaningful answers to these questions
instead of like coming up with like a F
effect size they want to like find um
and you can start to power against this
like well any positive effect is good
type of
scenario um and you see that that's kind
of what this graph does here and you can
you can start to have a conversation
about well look if you run a test for
three weeks and you want good power
against any feature that like isn't
losing US money um then you may have to
accept some small risk that it actually
will lose us like say like you know 1
and a half% conversion drop right and
maybe that's an acceptable risk and
maybe it's not an acceptable risk but
it's an assessment of risk that usually
they can reason about a little bit
better um and you end up with a more
productive conversation so that's
non-inferiority testing
um but there's another method that I
like that I want to talk to you about
and this
one directly sort of attacks the core
problem the core question that we have
in these test design
conversations uh and that is what's the
hurry right like why do we not have the
patients to run like an adequately
powered AB test in this organization
right what's going on why are we in such
a rush um and we sort of know the answer
right like running a test a long time is
costly There's an opportunity to cost a
time this gets back to that like the
nature of like the road mapping and the
the path dependence amongst features if
we're waiting a long time for a test of
what feature one that is that is going
to hold up feature two which depends on
the launch or the non- launch of feature
one and what happens right so hold road
maps get held up um there's the
opportunity cost of like sampling and
randomization and tests right by
construction of an AB test a bunch of
users are not getting the best version
of your site right um if you've ever
worked with Bandits or seen Bandits
you've seen them trying to approach this
problem um and then lastly there just
like the day-to-day maintenance cost of
tests right having a bunch of test
running on the site it wants is you know
engineering effort and like code
complexity and data storage and whatever
right usually that's small but it's it's
there so the question is right if we
know about all these costs and we know
they have effect how decision makers
want to run tests why aren't we
incorporating them into test designs
right uh and this is where value of
information experimental designs can
help so we know the time we spend
running a test longer is costly uh we
know the extra data we get from running
a test longer is valuable uh if we can
quantify the cost and we can quantify
the value that should be telling us how
long we should be running a test uh if
the value of more data exceeds the cost
of more data you should keep getting
data and if the cost of more data
exceeds the value of more data then you
should stop getting data right
um it's this picture here right uh the
longer our test run the more data we get
the more valuable that data is uh
additional data is less valuable when
you have a lot than when you have a
little right costs increase as you wait
to get that data if it's more valuable
to get the data then it is costly you
should get the data
right
um how do we think about the value of
data though right like what what is that
well before we run an experiment before
we have any data right we know very
little about what the conversion lift of
a new feature might be could be very
negative it could be very positive uh if
we make a decision based on our best
information now right we could end up
launching an awful feature or failing to
launch a really really good one right um
and then as we collect data right we
have a better idea of what that
conversion lift might be the range of
values it might take Narrows we may make
an incorrect guess now but our guess is
likely to be wrong by less um and it
turns out that you can put a value on
being probably less wrong um and if that
and again if that value exceeds the cost
of the time it takes to get that data
you should be getting
it so how do we actually say like
compute that value um that value of
being potentially less wrong um it turns
out it has a name it's called the
expected value of sample information
and I'm going to show you a really
simplified way of how you might estimate
it um so we start with a prior over what
we think the conversion lift might be
relatively wide range we don't know very
much could be pretty negative it could
be pretty
positive we are going to draw a bunch of
values out of that prior a bunch of
potential lifts out of that prior um for
each of those lifts that we draw uh
we're going to simulate an experiment
right let's say we're interested in like
hey what if I want to get get two more
weeks of data right so I can simulate an
exper a twoe experiment um control and
treatment with that lift that I drew out
of the prior that data and that prior
right generates a posterior with a new
opinion about what those lifts might
be each of those posteriors may change
my mind by may not change my mind at all
based on what I was going to do Under
the prior they may change my mind a lot
the prior um if an experiment generates
data likely to generate data that
changes my mind by a lot that was a
valuable experiment to run right if it
was never had never had any hope of
changing my mind there was no point in
doing it right um and so we run all
these simulations we get all these
priors we value the we get all the
posteriors we get the values we average
those out that's an estimate of this
expected value of getting this extra
data even better this is like an
inherently kind of sequential process
right um it's just posterior updating so
you can do it over and over again after
you get some data right you're really
just asking what's the value of some
more data and this changes the core
decision in an AB test from is B better
than a as though that's like a really
hard problem to figure out right to
should I stop getting data or should I
keep getting data right there's a good
fit for ab test because we don't have to
like recruit subjects for an AB test we
just have to like wait um you know and
then once more data isn't worth it you
just launch the best observed variant
the inference problem the statistical
significance problem is a at that point
we this is the best information we have
and I it's not worth getting more um so
there you are um and it turns out like I
find this a really compelling way to
think about AB tests with decision
makers um it directly gets at The Core
Concepts they think about when they want
to make a decision
right cost benefit time risk
everything's in dollars the outputs are
in dollars right they're not like you
know error rates right um
and it's it's it's more complicated than
traditional testing uh but it's
tractable for like a pretty broad range
of the kinds of ab tests um I I I I've
I've I've run in my experience um I've
built you know um you know there are
like open research questions on it it's
like an active area of research still
but it's it's I've built whole analytics
engines on it with r and shiny and
worked with product managers on it who
have found it you know um it gels really
well with how they want to make
decisions and kind of like liberates
them into being able to like oh I can
figure out how a test should work with
like dollar outputs right
um so those are those are the two
methods um and this is this is the part
of the talk where I'll reveal that I've
like failed to pay off on the clickbait
title per se um but hopefully there are
like some useful lessons um so the first
one is I'm not trying to sell you on
these specific two methods um I don't
think there's like a one-size fits-all
approach to AB testing uh in your
organization you're going to make
decisions differently you're going to
need to figure out what kind of
measurements you need to make to like
support those decisions um these have
Pros these have cons there's no Silver
Bullet uh but when you observe
stakeholders misusing the tools that you
have provided to them to do analyses
right um it should really cause you to
rethink oh what is this tool I've handed
it to them and does it align with how
they make decisions right does it align
with their concerns about risk and cost
and time and value and all that
important stuff am I giving them outputs
that map to how they think about the
problem uh and when I do that when I go
back and I try and rethink this right
about the the tools that I'm handing
them um you really want to get at am I
solving the core problem or am I just
solving the symptoms of the misuse that
I'm observing right launching on neutral
running a test till it's significant
peing like all this stuff are kind of a
symptom of the problem that the ab test
Frameworks we often work with don't deal
with the cost of time right
um um and there are like lots of
Advanced Techniques out there right
there's like coari adjustment sequential
P values and all this stuff that'll run
out that like will help a test go faster
right um and they're great and you
should use them when you can um but they
don't answer the question of like why
does this test need to go so fast and so
they're really just kind of treating the
symptom of of of of of impatience
right um
and this isn't just about AB testing
right data scientists like sometimes
like love a tool and like apply it not
super discriminately to problems and so
we end up with like lots of places where
like the tools we've handed stakeholders
aren't exactly like the perfect fit for
how they think about it um AB testing is
a really interesting case because it's
like a domain where you know it feels
like this is a solve statistical problem
this should be really straightforward
and then you go try and use it in
practice and it's like gets messy really
fast um
um um but this is I think the cool stuff
that we get to do um this is like a
vaguely weird time for data scientists
it feels like a lot of the problems we
used to work on are getting like
automated or like outsourced or
standardized or whatever right um but
these kinds of misalignments between
decision-making in an organization and
the data science tools used to support
those decisions happen like all over the
place and all the time in organizations
and um identifying those and addressing
them by you know going back to the first
principles of the problem and really
Translating that decision-making problem
into quantitative methods and
quantifying The Core Concepts in that
decision-making problem is where we can
like add value right um and I don't want
you to let like SAS vendors and like
chat GPT like convince you that these
are all solved problems and there's
nothing left to do I think there's a lot
of things like this to do out there
still um and I think that's what we're
here for right
um and that's all I have um I hope
thanks for coming everybody I hope you
enjoy the rest of
[Applause]
conference all right fantastic
so see if I can say this correctly is
there a risk of compounding poorly
tested changes into real deterioration
of the project so I've got a I've got a
yes but can you talk about that a little
bit yeah this is asking about the
non-inferiority stuff right if you're
willing to like accept a tiny loss on
each test right those starts to add up
um yes that's that absolutely can happen
um I would think the way I think about
this is having kind of an
aggregate uh inferiority margin budget
over a bunch of tests and going like
well you can put a margin on this one
and this one and this one but you can't
like you know this is like the total
loss that we can kind of accept over
like a long sequence of tests or for a
year over some unit of time and so you
have to like sort of budget out that
risk that you're you should you should
have a risk budget for all these
decisions right you don't want to think
about them in isolation
right okay fantastic let's let's thank
Carl
[Applause]
again